You know, we live in
a world of wonders--
high-tech gizmos that
boggle the imagination.
We enjoy every single day.
Devices that have
more complexity
and more technology
condensed into them
than $60 million
supercomputers had 40 years ago
are something we get
to enjoy every day.
The supercomputers of yesteryear
are in everybody's hands.
A young person with a
cell phone in Africa
has better communications
technology than the US
president had 25 years ago.
So there's no doubt that
these are magnificent machines
that we use to extend the
boundaries of our thinking
and of our reach.
Nonetheless, people have
this problem with technology,
because they think
it's somehow unnatural.
Enter Kevin Kelly.
Kevin Kelly's book What
Technology Wants introduces
the concept of the "technium."
He calls the technium
the aggregate
of all of our technology.
He calls it actually the
seventh kingdom of life.
He says the technium is
self-organizing, and has wants
and needs, and is subject
to evolutionary forces.
He literally says that
evolution is playing out
through the evolution
of technology.
Technology is birthed
out of the human mind.
If you were able to
time-lapse reality,
you would see our
thoughts spill over
into the world in the
form of technology.
We erect matter in
accordance with our will.
We reorganize the physical
materials of reality
and turn them into objects
of higher organization,
and we give them
transcendent qualities.
Today we have a device
made of plastic and metal
that sends our thoughts
traveling at light speed
across oceans of sky.
The fact that I can talk
on the phone with somebody
and have what Amber Case
refers to as "technologically
mediated telepathy,"
mind-to-mind communication,
is not just
astonishing, but also
according to Kevin
Kelly's idea, proof
of the flowering of
new possibilities.
Proof that technology
is a part of us.
It's made of atoms.
It's natural.
It sits on a continuum
between the born and the made.
Buckminster Fuller said start
with the universe, the Earth,
one single system,
an integrated system.
We are of nature.
Anything that is birthed out
of us is birthed out of nature.
So it's all good.
Nothing to worry about.